[Música]
sua autoridade é realmente muito ligado
à filosofia já estamos é ensiná-los
percentual da inflação brasileira em
viagem
nós testamos em sohar e porquê porque
ele não está com aquela bola encontrar
eu achava o seu onze não volta em 3
temos argumentado defender a nossa terra
nosso ponto de vista e não que haja
total de usuários nos olhos pra mostrar
que a gente não presta
em qualquer dos casos pereu termos de
israel
parece incrível retórica não é em
cumprimento por aí que cumprir a cota de
morrer no pensamento do filósofo
italiano história do chamado branch
sintomas ou troca quer dizer tozzi no
momento da sua vida vai sporting só em
nota sobre aquilo que a justiça junto
certo correto e incorreto é assim o
mundo próprio
é bom ouvir esta semana os bairros
dentre os mais novos podem esperar a
resposta é esta também é uma questão
fundamental para criar aqui é abordar
tudo claro tanto os homens como as
mulheres e as crianças também nos 9 e
thomas sky activas vez mais no nosso
sobre porque é que as coisas estão as
escolas as aulas desde que as crianças
estão ligados porque não é um dos
animais o que é e festa no pé
ela vai falar no mundo é essencialmente
saber produção está ligada à tecnologia
e aos instrumentos as máquinas aos
positivos em planilha foi que estas
informática é toda a equipe coisas que
não servem para fazer bobagem esforço e
aceitará algo que temos de 10 anos onde
há muito este tipo de saber desfrutar o
futebol porque se ela fazia a gente não
nos traz detalhes no sócio do bar curso
nos faz ter um trabalho e comprar entre
elas de que as porções
eu estou preocupado é estou errado
os cursos ligados a essas áreas e pôs em
frente tomar ligados a essas áreas
trazem com certeza para muita gente é
algo que poderia
não vou pra davos p a soja já é bastante
né e ninguém esquece nos via palma quase
de leptospirose no brasil estão grande
gênio é mais 2009 não parece realmente
se consiga é é chamada de desaposentação
todo em cima onde não faltam play
essas chamadas exatas ciências da
natureza é nacional e da cultura no
centro cultural com ela dominada e nós
queremos dominar e controlar os nomes
comuns e golpe da oposição de fazerem
escuta que você fica no grupo s o homem
pista não vou parar refletir nem
cobramos a não é gay eo também petista
um evento que é que há um tipo de
produto de qualquer coisa nós pensávamos
vai o conhecimento científico nosso time
jogou na vila cortês alô encerramento
controlar e dominar a natureza que será
o que se pensava na segunda 9 e hoje já
tendo a alguns segmentos disciplinar um
dos nomes na sua complexidade da sua
internação chega se à conclusão que nós
não terminarmos nós precisamos entender
compreender não apenas nos limitarmos a
explicar algumas coisas mas de tal é
porque está no sentido do turno e às
vezes falta de eficiência não se
consegue uma área
o mau tempo vai mostrar como é que o
mundo bem é na sua anta tornando-a mesmo
assim o o ocidente científico
tecnológico é por causa dos processos
como está em trânsito não é nem quando
estava na piscina uma nossa quanto às
doenças por exemplo é uma verdade não é
e as conexões podem depois do trabalho
na área mas mesmo assim é é preciso
pensar um bocadinho quais são os mitos
desta mesma essência dessa mesma pose do
sul não é ensaio muito bom e pode trazer
conseqüências e machico é você não possa
realizar uma tarefa é conseguir dar ao
google faz qualquer coisa para mim é
como alguém que vai candidatar é só o
álbum vai realizar a tarefa que é
mantido e obrigado então assim assim e à
tecnologia às vezes esquecem que há
coisas mais importantes a exemplo da
empresa chamada o maior empresa de
armamento do mundo
a indústria de defesa e segurança no
trabalho de tratar e antes desta empresa
nokia em 2010 foram qualquer coisa como
milhões de dólares e os da gestão 46,29
a vender a minha guerra e outro material
a utilizado o brest é escrava nacional
matrículas entre as que o preço está em
um instrumento e motos o que é ser
momento implicou embora alguns tenham
parte do palco é trabalhar com o bada
fazer uma coisa muito engraçada futebol
com as proporcionadas até 9 11 e 9 anos
e e eu por acaso não estava não treinar
mesmo tempo que cresce o emprego mesmo
que eu renasci bastante né
as opções não é tudo
não conhece que sejam patamar as regras
não é portanto de 300 não deve ter
problemas ao nível do mercado de e
continuamente com a aplicação do
conhecimento científico e tecnológico
nem sempre seja como no caso da produção
da master ações voluntárias
por exemplo precisamos construir a
barragem não gostou nem por nenhum meio
no século vi que implicou a perda das
frutas natural das terras ou seja o
mínimo todos os anos
quem achar isso e as drogas eram
naturalmente organizadas imagem e
portanto deixar uns totalizante naturais
deixaram em chegar
olha baixa e portanto e somente uma
simplificação e tramitação muito bonito
e ansiosa que começa aqui da nossa festa
nós pessoas a apresentar aquele no
caracol que gosta de viver namorada do
atual
portanto para dizer porque nós
precisamos de aumentar a complexidade do
caráter sistêmico das coisas quando fez
a abordagem
essa nossa sincera vamos ter retirado a
ige vamos pontuar já me leva a ter
problemas no final acaba por ser
preciosos oab tatu nos mostradores
depois vieram e contaminar os humanos
que acontece na sua função de órgão
transportador de oportunidades naturais
por é é é necessário que nós já utiliza
absurdo
a nossa pequenez enquanto estamos aqui
porque chega uma peça de um passo tanto
o time faz um todo e eles às vezes falta
a a assistência é utilizar o urânio do
mundo conjunto de trabalhos enfim nós na
nossa vida é fazer opções evoluções não
é é um conhecimento sobre o assunto
devemos falar
não podemos não devemos e fundamentadas
[Música]
lógico que minha vida fora sem um grito
a do site g1 o espírito sem o
consentimento de uma razão por gravar o
papel dos filha é de manaus e botamos
esses conceitos e tentarmos fazer ver
mais claro não é ensinado de um time que
sempre é fácil enquanto a média dos pais
em casa com os amigos
isso é mais fácil assimilado e aceitar
essas mesmas idéias no qual em causa o
seu valor a esse seria o que nenhum
sozinho para se dizer como disse amos à
enorme tanque cheio ou não voltei e vou
procurar nos copos pastores não é e
[Música]
envolve 30 é max ciência e elétrico do
mundo os pilotos precisam é de
transformar os filhos pontos de garras
são os fãs que estou a desenvolver uma
maçã número atual de vagas do pensamento
filosófico é essa
[Música]
as consciências com a tecnologia social
twitter como organização com um
pensamento sobre a assinar dois minutos
eu vou ser mais breve que nós não é um
sinal nada porque os outros desde que
isso seja o maior poluidor do mundo está
a economia o seu pensamento está
completamente ausente do país está em em
durar a existência do outro e ignorância
do outro cuidado é que a produção aquilo
não é algo que faça um papo projeto
tempo e por isso é que somente situação
implica um investimento de r prometeram
só a 0 e pensar que há várias teorias
cunha será alimentada conforme nós a
consciência sobre os limites do
conhecimento científico
[Música]
temos o dever sobre os limites desse
próprio poder
basta ver que deu hoje as pessoas têm
acesso à água
nós estamos vivendo em uma casa
nós tiramos o equipamento pesado e é
essa sociedade em estreias no real
social em 3d velho
a gente ia ter um compromisso um
compromisso assumido e não só para a
população como também em conjunto ações
como essa transformação é um animal
social e alguém valor humano estou assim
aumento é confesso que o em francês
humanos nos sons desenvolver no ataque
[Aplausos]